from screen jumping studio in the heart
of Los Angeles this is screen junkies
boutique right now your host Andy signor
hello screen junkies I am NOT Andy
signor Amy's away on assignment I am Dan
merle and we are here for a very special
edition of movie fight scars three is
hitting theaters this weekend and we
thought what better time to do pixar
fights so we are doing a fight with all
things tech star today we are talking
about things like the best vocal
performance at any pixar movie who's the
best Pixar character and we're going to
have our panelists pitch me the best
explanation for the Cars universe and
the best one wins it's going to be a lot
of fun and we are super excited to have
a very talented very prestigious panel
of fighters with us today first of all
the gentleman on my left you might
remember him from our debut deathmatch
you made a big splash earlier this year
a lot of people wanted to see him back
welcome back to the show mr. and grier
egg welcome back thank you so much for
having me back Dan that this is a great
opportunity to talk about some stuff I
really like and uh to give the fans what
they want they were like dumbness bordo
that's the slogan of the show movie
fights we bring more dumbness city likes
to add oh she made a big splash she
started at the beginning and she was one
of the two last fighters standing on our
collider edition of last fighter
standing she is a writer and a producer
at Collider Perry Nemiroff Perry welcome
back oh thank you for having me back I
think the only way that I was possibly
going to walk into this just a little
less nervous than usual
is having this being the next thing
after what we did last time with the
whole Collider team because that last
quarter standing thing was intense
that was a good time and I have some
sympathy because that happened to me too
I started to begin and got all the way
the end and just came up short so
welcome back this is a regular fight
you're not gonna have to fight off a
whole gang of people just a night
and finally oh we are so happy to have
this guy he's the host of cinema holux
and you may have seen that something on
the internet called the Pixar theory
which kind of suggested a way that all
the movies could be interconnected he's
the guy behind it please welcome John
Negroni John welcome to movie fights
thank you for coming by the way thanks
for letting me come on and have some fun
with you guys I am so ready to do
to the first time now the Pixar theory
kind of blew up and took the internet by
storm was that something you expected or
were you just kind of sit around go like
hey I have some interesting ideas about
how these movies are maybe all connected
together like that
yeah there's looks like this might be
interesting and I spent a lot of time on
it and then for some reason people were
like yeah I believe you can trust you
and it's been weird ever since but
hopefully we can have some cool stuff
coming out eventually like the layers
like an updated like new and Imperials
kind of Pixar theories maybe Wow so that
was our point oh yeah yeah yeah
especially for the haters oh I love it I
love it well thank you for bringing your
expertise to this show and because I'm
sitting here that means we have to have
somebody checking all the facts and that
is why we have our own Game Master lawn
Harris lon that's me thank you and
throwing it over on the fact-checking
cam oh my pleasure to be here for Pixar
fights I may have just met all of you
but I love you oh one is right my god
you look lovable guy in the office we
all just go give him a hug Roberto it's
like this is easy it's like a walking
Pixar movie Lodge thank you so much
we'll be going to you when we need some
clarification on the facts over here and
guys before we start just a reminder
this is of course you know your pics are
important but this is based on the
arguments I will be judging you based on
your creativity based on your passion
and just overall clarity of arguments so
just because you picked what you think
is the right answer doesn't necessarily
mean it's the best argument you've got
to defend those picks any questions get
together pretty alright then let's get
it on let's start the fight give me what
I'm normally nice
I am NOT a deterrent
that sounds like very appropriate for
Pixar fences it's all ultraviolence
all right guys round one of our six star
fight a lot of these questions came from
fans we get a lot of great questions
from fans on Twitter we ask for some
pixar questions this comes from at
Sinatra Frank 151 who I'm just going to
assume with the actual Frank Sinatra
from wherever from the grave and big
Pixar fan wants to know who is the best
Pixar character now a lot of great
choices here a lot of really good ones
to choose from I think everyone's going
to take a say up upfront everyone's
going to pick really good characters so
this is all about defending yours and
also telling me why your pick is better
than the other two and I will start with
you okay my character that I picked was
Carl Pettersson from up I really feel as
though Carl out of all the characters
and pick stars can and he's one of the
best designed he's got this nice little
blocky look to him even his eyebrows are
blocky his hair is blocky his face is
blocky and it's for a reason because
he's boxed into his reality right now
like and he's also just sort of a
resistant little dude you know so I and
I think he's very uniquely designed in
regards to they said like he could only
turn his head 15 degrees or so before he
had to turn his whole body to represent
how old he was and also he that movie
was one of it was one of the only two
animated movies to be nominated for a
Best Picture Oscar along with best along
with Beauty and the Beast so I feel like
if you have a dude that central to a
story that got a Best Picture nominee in
a time when they didn't they didn't just
hand those out my candy I feel as though
that is a strong opening statement for
why Carl wasn't a very good opening
statement and we'll hear a lot more from
you from car about Carl Perry what's
your choice surprise surprise I'm going
with wall-e and I'll get the obvious out
of the way first I'm taking Molly for
one reason because clearly he is the
cutest freakin thing ever
wall-e spends like so many toys I
created a Lego out of wall-e that's just
how much people love wall-e and they
want to own wall-e in so many different
forms but then just talking
him as a character in the actual movie
look at the beginning of that movie it
is really mind-blowing how much
character they get across in those
opening sequences when while he's the
character that doesn't really speak at
all and still in those opening sequences
they throw in so much detail as to you
know who Wally is the fact that he's a
diligent worker and he's going to keep
doing what he's doing yet he also gets
distracted and all the little things he
picks builds so many layers within
minutes and then the second Eve comes in
there's a whole new side to Wally and
then the second he gets to the axiom it
continues to build and even though I
think Wally is more so about Wally as a
character being true to who he is and
changing everybody around him he still
is really great at adapting to his
surroundings and then just talk about
the animation when while he came out
that kind of changed the game in a whole
new way for Pixar the level of detail in
that animation and specifically Wally as
a character himself the functionality of
that character and how they worked it in
is absolutely stunning and it inspired
Pixar to take some risks make some
characters that are a little offbeat and
try new design elements so I think
wall-e is hands-down the best all right
an argument for wily John who did you
pick as the best Pixar character I went
with and this was stuff because I wanted
to pick a Pixar character that just has
so much so much we can learn from him so
I picked woody from the Toy Story movies
you know one of the advantages here is
that we spent a lot of time with woody
and we like I said have learned so many
things from a character who in every
single movie he's been in he has been so
different in each one and yet still
entirely the same when we start with him
he's this character who is so believable
in the way that he experiences like
human emotions without it being even
though he's like a toy it is always
struck need to be so amazing he's an
iconic character he's a character who
you know he reacts to these situations
and all three of the movies that even
I'm sitting there and I'm wondering what
would I even do in that situation so
when he makes mistakes I actually for a
moment and thinking I can't blame him
she's a character full of empathy he's a
character who
we've stuck with four to all these
movies and we just keep getting more and
more out of his stories and how he's
still the heart of the Toy Story movies
three movies later it's amazing so yeah
undisputable I mean if you take a look
at everything that he offers everything
that he contributes to the entire Pixar
canon of movies he has done the most
work and he should be the most respected
as the most well-rounded Pixar character
all right three great choices Carl from
up wall-e and woody again you guys have
ticket as to why your choice is the best
out of those three Duke it out oh man I
mean they're all really great characters
first off but I think Carl might be the
easiest one to eliminate just because
Carl is Carlin special because of the
situation he's in so much of him comes
from Russell and everything that's
happening around him and you know even
though he does have his moment at the
end where he changed changes he is a
cold character for 95% of the movie and
I were talking about although it's like
is same thing with wall-e is that I
think it's really weird to take a Pixar
character who's one-half of a romance
because so much of both wall-e and Carl
is wrapped up in Ellie so I'm not
convinced that either of those
characters is the best character in
their own movie because they're so
reliant on the yeah character Alan
Carroll is not he has his relationship
with Eve he is the beginning the first
act of the movie where it is just him
being him and in the Cosmo has and Hal
the cockroach but then there's also the
third act of the movie when he has a
responsibility to make sure the greater
good happens and they get back to earth
I think is very reactive during those
scenes though like a lot of stuff that
happens for the end is all spurred on by
Eve and he is like I mean in the very
end it's not really him who saves the
day it's Eve even everybody around him
he's also you bring up the fact that
what he's an inspiring character look at
wall-e because sometimes we just need to
take a step back and think you know look
at how wall-e is driven by the simple
things in life those little tiny things
that just make him happy and the fact
that all things true love you incredible
stuff
as children here honestly I don't even
get what we're fighting about here
that's my s myopic and that's what I
always do but honestly I mean we've got
a robot who never counter man's his
programming every single improvisation I
every single improvisation he does is to
do this central thing he was supposed to
do which is clean up and he gets maybe a
new goal when he starts talking some
space broad he gets a new goal you know
not a romance it's one way baby she's
got laser guns that she's about to be no
man and here comes a wily trying to roll
up in our life literally and and you
talked about he had a unique design
elements he's a sawn-off Johnny Five
he's a sort of driving like that's not a
yeah I never met at all it's a direct
opposite of that he also woody you know
get off buddy your robots ooh what is
this stupid robot removing do you mean
me to be with Andy rule book at least
Carla he has written goal of Asians in
the air kicks our character Carl has
unique motivations he wants to put his
freakin house on a mountain yes but the
were imported by motivation actually
like really so it's Andy to because one
of your arguments was that Wally is just
about his love to Eve and Carl is just
about his love for Ellie look I mean
look at what that part of the reason why
I didn't choose woody is because woody
isn't a special and is memorable without
the other toys and Andy's remember
without his relationship to Andy I agree
guys because all of Woody's most
important scenes don't have Andy in them
they're always woody coming to terms
with first of all it's the existential
questions in Toy Story 2 there's all the
humor that he adds you both mentioned
characters that I would argue for most
of their movies aren't very funny but
everything that happens on what at least
while you're here but honestly on some
real stuff my character is not is not an
otamatone car my character at the very
least is flesh and blood with real
people concerns that the aging montage
with him and his wife how they couldn't
they can't afford all the stuff and his
life got in the way
life doesn't get in the way for a
freaking robot or a dumbass toy but
these blighters nothing to remove their
life life because they're not alive
because your guys not alive my guys my
organ
I gotta live the court the court will
seize the point that Karl is the human
being is that these two are not usually
what I think what I think we'll see that
point and and due to the fact of that
they are harder to be the best character
because they're harder to be characters
in the first place when they're not even
real I know we're some animated movie
but still are all is humorless and he's
pretty Jewish people say it has an arc
isn't you know that being a robot
there's a robot and you're going to
remain a toy it was a toy and he goes
through from being oh he goes to a Dark
Knight Returns change he can't even move
his neck he rides a thing really enjoy
so you know he would ride he rides up
the stairs on a freakin gremlins machine
that takes all people to stairs by the
end he's doing monkey bars on a
dirigible because he's awakened he's a
new man from him and everything what he
does have so much more agency everything
that he does is so much more compelling
in all three movies what is i doing
marry Harry while he does everything I
can half of Wally's of chasing whereas
not general also there's a scene with
purpose not only for him and for Eve but
I mean humanity and existence but all
through the blood of Jesus lolly is an
absolutely hilarious character
especially in that opening bit where he
doesn't even speak there's so many
little movements and gestures that make
you make you one lap and smile if
anybody out there watches wall-e with a
scowl on their face tonight I argued I
argued for wall-e as most adorable
character ever and was trounced
even though I was better than my
opponents because of the fact that one
of one of the things are going to get
with a Mogwai they suck nobody like them
but a Mogwai with fur and babe the pig
beat wall-e and I'm sorry it's because
well Lee's a robot and it's hard to
identify with them now one thing I think
identified why leotards identify in the
opening sequence it's not hard to
identify why it's the point to the
opening brief of him is to give him
humanity and show that yes he was a
robot but he has these special quirks
and that's why he's unique any flash I
absolutely agree that Wally's opening
was the second best she heard of our
character montage in the world but mine
was the first crawl was called
makes people cry who don't even see the
rest of the booty but here's the problem
both of your movies are half of a good
movie I think that all the wall-e and
karl-frederik would is only in the first
half
whereas Toy Story is a fully good movie
three times and it's such a good
character and alright Paul Gauguin
Cartagena Carol you are here another
character is Kevin Durant
he's on a great name and that's why he
win cannot record me so great your
characters are great team yeah I just
find her on the old Bowl I feel like
I've heard a lot about Carl and Woodend
and Wally but I do want to hear a little
bit from you Perry about woody
particularly why you think that Woody's
why I think why do I have not you know
as good as your pick or well part or the
reason why Wally is the best character
is because whereas both it's like all of
the Oscar Oh like what he's great in
three films is that we're not talking
about the film we're talking about the
character and the cool thing about Wally
is Wally is that movie he drives the
entire movie and it is so incredibly
well structured with his journey being
different the first our second act third
act his his whole experience there is
moving every single step of the way and
every step of the way he accomplishes
something completely different that adds
to his character and the point of Wally
is that he is a robot with a personality
and with humanity I'm not just talking
about his relationship with Eve it's his
relationship with everything and how he
processes everything that's happening
around him so he is he is not literally
human but he is just as human as any as
someone like Carl I was I'm going to
tell you that the great closing
statement for Wally and I think that's
great so Perry that's I live think it's
great with for Wally Edie give me a
closing statement on Carl why Carl again
not so much why he's why he's a great
character but why is he better than
their tears Oh again he is better than
their two choices because number one he
is a human being with an actual human
journey now obviously this movie is very
whimsical he's have to half the movie
he's toing a house on balloon so we're
not dealing with reality here but it
does show some of the realities of life
you don't always get to do what you want
to do in the time that you want to do it
sometimes you do need to pursue your
goals when when it's supposedly too late
and guess what you'll find off times
when you do what you want and you really
pursued your goal it's never too late
and you can do what you want
that is a message that is really dope
and it's better than the slavish
devotion of a robot and a toy
very good all right so ed that's a
closing on Carl and then John I closed
me out on woody why is wedding better
than these two choices I think one of
the things we're overlooking here is
that I mean what are the things that
these characters want that's so much of
what makes a good character what Carl
wants to do is very simple he wants to
go to Paradise Falls and honestly like
his mission is mostly symbolic and it's
not very consistent with like how he
reacts with Russell from up a movie
that's why the movie for me isn't as
great I don't think he's a great main
character and I would say for wall-e
it's the same kind of thing you just you
have this character whose two things
cuteness and whimsy and I think the
movie gets out in the first half and the
second half Eve steals all of his scenes
but in Toy Story you have three movies
with three separate individual story
arcs all championed by this one woody
character that even though he's the
movies about a toy who like we're not
told that he's a toy acting like a
person we're like we have to connect
with a toy a thing that you said wasn't
alive and they pull that off that is
what makes them so different from all
the other Pixar characters is that they
did it three times and was a three movie
act I mean one of their character in
fiction history has had such an amazing
journey like from movie to movie it's
everything from loyalty feeling like
you're getting replaced feeling like how
am I like dealing with the idea that
you're going to die and get thrown away
or put into storage and then moving on
to some loving somebody new these are
all things that aren't overland Andy
they just show how human a toy can be
and to me that's way more interesting
all right that was a WoW I'm going to
use lines time to say that yeah look at
my notes here cuz those are really great
arguments lon any anything we need to
clean up there uh you know I didn't I
didn't see any major fact issues
everybody it seemed like a pretty clean
round on Twitter we had a lot of support
for inside out and monsters ain't
characters that weren't mentioned sorrow
and sadness coming
but I'm a question about would we have
accepted Riley as a choice because she
can bodies all of those emotional
manners and proceed with caution I would
be very careful would be one wet yeah
very slippery slope so a lot of people
surprised Buzz Lightyear didn't come up
considering that woody was a choice uh
many people John upset by saying that he
feels the wall-e and up fall-off in the
second half there was a lot of pushback
on the internet about that and then Tom
our viewer is going to try the wall-e
watch with a scowl challenge and I'm
submission one we have two offices and
that's not once in a while it's a little
weather often did it once yeah or more
than once I taught you the best ice
admission that we have appe enjoy today
right next to you Richard Higginbotham
hey Richard welcome what's up welcome do
we fight you excited to be a bigger
fight yeah especially with my sister you
can't see her right now but she's uh she
doesn't really know much about movies no
offense but we grew up on Pixar so it's
good to be here on this fight so thank
you for having us awesome well Richard
thank you for coming and I'm going to be
going to you during the speed round and
maybe during the show also to get your
thoughts because I can already tell
there's going to be some very difficult
decisions to make and to get to this
decision I think that Edie
Perry and John I hear your argument
about the fact that Karl is a human that
it's that you know you it's a little
easier to relate to him because he could
be emotion of the story and everything
but I feel like they kind of argued both
of their characters and knocked you out
a little bit and that was a big part of
your argument so I had to eliminate Karl
for me came down between Wally and woody
and I think Perry Jon you both made
really good arguments Perry talking
about the fact that you the whole first
act and you connect with them even
though you know you're just watching go
about his business and and John kind of
talking about the overall arc of woody
and I think really the closing statement
is kind of ugly over the top you two
were neck and neck but John I think you
had the advantage with woody of having a
character who had a free movie arc
who you could kind of point out a little
bit more of a character detail about his
journey and why that made a mess
a character so many does that first
point to John but very close very good
job everybody all if you're listening I
love ice it hurts I would like to
apologize a while of all I believe on
tourism oh yes a lot I'm so sorry what
were our poles the internet largely
agreed to 51% for woody 32% for Molly
17% for carl fredrik all great
characters though it's going to be
recurring theme I think on today's five
because six are so many fun movies that
you know this I think there's easy
answers for every round but let's move
on to round two and this is another
Twitter question it comes from DX arts
Bader's I'm not even going to try to
pronounce that phonetically who asks
what is the best vocal performance in
any Pixar movie now them from the
character this is they had you know a
parade of a listers that have done
performances all their characters but
which one stands up to you is the best
and this time we're going to start with
Perry alright I am saying Amy Poehler as
joy and really I don't think it's any
contest no matter who comes up in this
fight because the thing about her vocal
performance as joy is joy as a character
that only works because of the way that
Amy Poehler delivers every single line
that is a character that is she is joy
she's enthusiastic she's chipper and she
could run the risk of being obnoxious so
you need to have someone like Amy
Poehler who can tow that line between
one expressing that but never becoming
annoying and then also Joyce whole arc
in that movie is that she has to come to
terms with the fact that sadness needs
to be in control sometime and Amy
Poehler manages to do that and it is
definitely I mean there's a lot of other
factors in play too but largely because
of her vocal performance you can see
that joy stays joy she stays true to her
emotion but she also comes to accept and
understand that they need to work
together and sometimes joy can't be
front and center because Riley needs
sadness she needs sadness to experience
joy I think a lot of that characters are
comes through Amy Poehler's performance
and one of the big things is the fact
that nobody else could have voiced her
the
same way I am absolutely convinced that
there is no other actors who could have
turned joy into such a successful
character whereas I appreciate many
other Pixar characters out there and the
actors who voiced them I can't think of
a single one who I can't swap for
somebody else or who couldn't have done
that great of a job and going back to
the animation her vocal performance in
that is also key because there's another
example of Pixar taking risks and trying
a character that might not have worked
and then also adding new animation
elements to her which cost a lot of
money and you know when you have a
really well-written script and someone
to perform it you can take those risk
and you can push the animation further
because your main character is
exceptional and it's largely because of
Amy Poehler all right very very very
joyful about Amy Poehler John what is
your pick my pick is Ellen DeGeneres who
is the voice of Dorian finding nemo and
finding dory of course and I mean my
goodness what Ellen does with the
character of Dory
I'm so convinced that Finding Nemo
wouldn't be half as good if not for that
vocal performance and since I consider
finding email to be if one of if not the
best Pixar movie I'm very grateful for
that vocal performance I'm grateful for
the two things that I think make up a
great performance overall I think it's
the range I think it's you have to have
a character that can do a lot of
different things I mean you can have a
character who does you know a decent job
is like the role that they're given my
gosh like Dory first of all is the
funniest Pixar character by far and
she's in what I would say is the
funniest Pixar movie
so like the fact that she can bring on a
lot of the movies best humor but always
be able to turn that on and off when the
movie needs to call for dramatic action
scenes for moments between her and
Marlin it is just amazing what Ellen is
able to do with this voice I think that
she did a great job
I'm just being dynamic with the
character and sharing real growth from
beginning to end and it's just an iconic
voice but you can't unhear it when you
hear it and of course she has the most
lovable lines just keep swimming she can
speak well I mean there's just so much
going on there so props don't all right
Edie what was your pick
yeah I feel like sentimentality is going
to beat me again because I my character
that I picked was a Craig T Nelson's
performance as mr. incredible in The
Incredibles now it's obviously not as
much of this sort of star turn as the
Dory situation or maybe Poehler but he
carries that movie and he plays multiple
Craig T Nelson crate he plays multiple
characters in that movie in regards to
when we first meet mr. incredible he's
he's a 50s sort of hey I've got on but
I'm gonna save the day type guy at the
top of his game then we see him as an
office drone who's beaten down by
bureaucracy and that's a difference
there's a different vocal tone to him he
doesn't play that a character but he has
a have different characteristics
he has actually act it's not just a
vocal trick or this is a cute voice w
recognize he has to actually act these
emotions of being downtrodden then
hiding all the superhero dumb from his
wife then eventually growing into a
character that will have his wife and
his kids be part of his life again
instead of doing clandestine stuff
behind their backs and you know just so
there she's got such a great arc that
has that only comes through really
through his vocal performance and
through his line reading so I feel as
though his performance really helps that
perfect the most perfect of all Pixar
movies in my personal opinion movie hum
because he is so perfect and so good all
right guys correctiy Nelson Amy Poehler
Ellen DeGeneres all three memorable
characters remember we're talking about
the performance fight it out I don't
want to be mean - Craig - yeah I don't
but he's also compared compared to dory
he is not it's not ever indispensable
it's not an indispensable vocal
performance I can think of like dozens
of other actors that could have done
about the same as him there are maybe
some I don't think they could run to the
head part I don't think they could bring
the bad news in his voice just think and
the role of yes I feel like that's both
those things are really hard to get in
one actor I can just have Josh Brolin
where I was on the big screen right now
though a lot of them do do the hero part
really well but a lot of them have
really human elements too and I just
coming up with a list in my head
I just started to look at you know my
Marvel and DC movies and started to put
actors in there and I'm not talking
about them imitating what they're doing
with those characters in those movies
but I think they could achieve the same
I will say Ellen sue Ellen's a little
tougher to argue against because yes
it's similar to Amy Poehler in that it
is an iconic performance and I think
when you think about Finding Nemo
finding Dory Dory and you think about
inside out that is probably some of your
best shots and all the Pixar movies to
thank that vocal performance from that
person however I think in this case
finding Dory is almost the pitfall here
because even though finding Dory is an
excellent movie a lot of the criticism I
heard is that there's a little too much
Ellen there's a little too much Ellen
acting as silly Dory saying the same
lines over and over again and I think
that should they come out with another
one of those movies and Dory is in it
front and center or a supporting
character it's going to start to parade
I would also agree because I because
Dory delivers all of the humor and
finding Dory that's very effective the
theme with Amy Poehler and I was
thinking this even when I was watching
inside out it felt derivative of Dory it
felt like they were doing this down a
tall thing and one of the big
differences between Amy Pond and Ellen
DeGeneres both amazing people is that
for this you mentioned it this is a star
turn for Ellen for Amy Poehler not so
much the thing that I have the biggest
problem with with Amy Poehler's vocal
performance is the famous sadness I
could only hear any polar from Parks and
Recreation I can only hear Leslie know
because she didn't do anything with that
vocal performance that's why I want to
jump on I want to jump on yeah having
Leslie Knope decide exactly what you're
supposed to be feeling and in what order
you should feel it would be hell that
would be hell and that is what you're
proposing what and that's what I feel
when you hear but also with what Ellen
DeGeneres I'm sorry man
if I just swim with that broad for 15
minutes i puncher indices been able to
save yourself optimistic and oh well
come on Amy Poehler as joy is someone
who inspires you to be optimistic and
really believe it and run with it where
is Gauri almost annoys me to the point
of wanting to like just chill out
sit inside I think they're hitting you
pretty hard on the obnoxiousness do you
disagree with it with the dories I was
going to say that I would see joy is
clear the more obnoxious ones and this
isn't so
objectives if you take a look at the
vocal performance with her it is so say
me throughout there's one change for the
very end where she starts crying and
that's some rich but Dori that entire
movie it is like her comedic timing like
the things that she comes in it's so
much more unexpected with joy I knew
what she was going to say but do I think
I were you the same the exact opposite
argument where Dori does feel OneNote
and it's more about her adventure and
I'm just talking about finding story
with finding her parents it is kind of
the same character going on that journey
where we're calling my way
exactly represents a whole arc event
movie events of coloring in Riley's mind
as things start to get gray and lose
their color you start to hear it in Amy
Poehler's voice yeah I don't know if
you're projecting but what can I do I
only one here I haven't interesting much
about correcting elephants I'm curious
what you think about you started off
with it and you know I could just get
into the fact that the best vocal
performance in there is actually Alan or
Helen sorry because I honestly like
every scene where Crichton else's are
cartoony he's missing his neighbor Craig
right now yeah Robinson in beginning
Christine Nelson every scene where she
is competing with another voice actor I
think they still have seen from him and
the mode especially highbrow but again I
think that I think your undervaluing
real team basketball in regards to this
sort of acting jazz that we're doing
here their budget and they're a bunch of
jerks in the room trying to approximate
a family everybody can't do a star turn
Joel Dory calling joy one note is like
dory calling Marlin wet and they're both
garbage and very very OneNote when every
little helping Ron I feel as though I
feel like though this is very much like
when Denzel Washington lost a best
acting award to Al Pacino doing a
caricature of himself
it is a Washington had to play pre pre
Muslim stuff Malcolm in the streets
welcome street hustler guy young Muslim
guy ocean captain bubble guy el Hadj
Malik Shabazz and then a dead guy he put
like six characters over the course that
thing I feel as though something happens
similar with Craig T Robinson I've
excused
like something similar happens with
Craig D where he is he is the court upon
which everybody plays but there has to
be a solid foundation under you for all
these starters like Edna mode
he's just playing team ball he's not
he's not hogging the ball and I thought
a lot of those scenes that you're
talking about he's very gravely he's
very dark and depressed and there's just
nothing all that special about it we're
talking about a vocal performance that
it is going to be a classic it's
something that has so many quotable
lines both of your carriers are live
characters they're bright and very small
it's very small now I wasn't that behind
at whatever here cancel no I'm not
talked about so now that there's a
Batman characters who are just sort of a
caricature for three minutes and then
you get tired of them because I know I
was tired of joy by the end and I kind
of Dory most of the second I'm a
political performance and is perfect
that emails and feels replaceable is
just kind of the killer in that right
now until you actually I put a half of
the people you put on your little list
unless they're Kevin Conroy or something
like that I have to be put on your back
can't fail in the family aspect or in
the heroic aspect and I scanned or the
dad family aspect and I said well if I
said it in another oh no I can't
apologize interesting how you talk to a
villain how you talk to your kids is
different than how you talk to a Billy
you guys have all is Visser ated each
other's choices well I mean that
everybody's throwing haymakers so just
to wrap it up again I want to get each
of your thoughts on your choice and
again not the characters necessarily but
why your choice represents the best
vocal performance out of all of these
Jonel stealth okay I think that Ellen
had the hardest job out of all three of
these characters I mean for her Leslie
Knope / Amy Poehler she sort of how to
play herself just be optimistic and get
a little sad toward the end and I think
that she doesn't
most of that movie I spent a lot of time
wishing that we had Lewis Black who I
think had a more memorable vocal
performance there but with Dory I mean
again she steals every scene that she's
in she I think that it wasn't given
enough testament to director Andrew
Stanton who looked at Ellen and looked
how this character how to not be a tow
mater before tow mater even existed
and be not a survived character not even
a supporting character but in her own
way she's sort of she's not just like
any of that so she's like the heart of
this movie and she's not even the main
protagonist and she is what makes funny
Nemo so just like people are never going
to hear that movie its most successful
Pixar movie and not getting along that
obviously but yeah so so Ellen DeGeneres
she had the hardest job and I think with
director Andrew Stanton this is a
character whose vocal performance it has
perfect timing with the animation too
because all of her movement although all
the scenes that she's in where she's
competing with these other voice actors
Albert Brooks I would not want that job
she is nailing it every single time
there's not a weak Dory scene in either
of those two movies awesome and Perry
Amy Poehler I mean really this whole
argument comes down to the fact that Amy
Poehler is irreplaceable as joy and the
fact that a lot of what you say about
Dory is kind of similar to what is
what's Amy Poehler's responsibility as
being joy and whereas Amy Poehler kind
of Ti mended Ellen DeGeneres kind of
teeters on the line of being annoying
for some people and she's also a side
character and filled with those quick
one-liners and those little gags Amy
Poehler as joy is the entire heart of
that movie yes it is Riley story and she
is one emotion in her mind but it really
is just as much a joy story as it is
Riley's and the fact that Amy Poehler's
performance one does be incredible and
is not obnoxious when that character is
pretty much written that way it also
really reflects Riley's journey
throughout the entire time because joy
does change she is one of motion she has
to be that one emotion but she also has
to change and come to terms with where
she stands amongst the other emotions
and what is best for Riley and I think
you can hear that in her work and the
way she works with everybody else I mean
the the whole ensemble thing was brought
up and with Amy Poehler being joy amidst
those other emotions I don't think
there's any more of an important place
for someone to be able to play off other
people really well where they can still
have their moments to shine but she also
is the heart of the movie because that's
really that's really what emotions are
about they're about working together and
if inside out taught me anything it's
that
right and add Crick T Nelson much like
father's all over the place you guys do
not appreciate what incredible is doing
in that movie only as your way into an
entire new superhero universe do you
know why nobody does superhero stuff
unless it's Marvel or DC because trying
to create your own superhero universe is
super hard and nobody relates to it and
they always compare you unfavorably to
other types of comic-book stuff whereas
everybody in the world knows the best
Fantastic Four movie that was ever made
is The Incredibles he they literally
took the entire format and did it way
better and as a character I would love a
mr. incredible more than the thing
inside track I'm saying is the bottom
line is he's doing a lot of heavy
lifting literally and figuratively in
that movie he's providing a court for
everybody to play and his change as a
character is palpable whereas I do not
believe Dory's is nor do I believe
really Joyce's joyjoy has a temporary
moment of man and then she goes back to
being what she is he goes from a person
who is beaten down and broken to
somebody who's saving the world with his
family and with someone who's willing to
open himself up to having everybody come
join him and that joy rather than hiding
it from them and all of these things are
he's doing it just with his voice and
there are times where he's not just
gravelly or family there's a million
times when he's discovering all the dead
bodies in the cave that syndrome' killed
and there's a lot to his performance
that is underappreciated much like dads
in this country so correcting that a
passionate defense of Ricky Nelson and
many other things it's interesting I
love an American family blonde anything
to clean up there we already sort of
picked up on Craig T Nelson vs. Craig
Robinson a lot of gifts to my feet and
the dancing craig robinson
british fix our checks jackie muhammad
twitter wants to know about your Top Gun
shirt yes so this was Top Gun and
interstellar allowed reference explained
yes yes so Lazarus was the mission that
they go on to save Matt Damon and and
the other people too this is the black
hole this is the ship that Matt Damon
blows up spoiler takes yeah I know
interstellar isn't the favorite of
people well they I brought it hoping to
piss off Spencer but I don't see him so
so you're welcome Witter and then a ton
of alternate suggestions for
performances Richard kindest being bomb
came up number one Patton Oswald is Remy
Billy Crystal was Mike Wazowski both Tom
Hanks and Tim Allen back and forth and
samuel l jackson is Frozone
came up several oh wow yeah very all
them very memorable performance i don't
like any on the nose yeah there's gonna
be tough category first of all John that
can I please your Pixar theory when
you're done with the second can you
please write a story on Pixar called how
not to be a tow later because Ellen my
Ellen biography how not to be a no mater
that I think that depicts our book that
people would like to read you all very
passionate about your selection so it
kind of comes down to what people said
against yours and then kind of your
passion in defending what you wanted and
I think that you know it's very close
but to me I think it actually came down
and I know you're concerned about
getting out sentimental but I actually
think that your argument for correctiy
Nelson again about his performance the
fact that he provides a playground for
everyone to play in and he plays all
these different levels of the character
it was similar to your argument about
joy Perry but I think that and actually
sold me a little bit better on
correcting Nelson and why it was the
best performance and so as very close
when I was three and I think I'm gonna
give you the point there actually or
Christine okay
[Music]
what was the the fan poll on they take
some issue with you 42% of them went for
Dori Ellen DeGeneres a story 30% win for
Amy Poehler as joy 28% went Craig T
Nelson as Bob Parr / mr. grodman is the
man in this room if the arms are very
very close to fight a very tough fight
you all picked great choices that's why
we brought you on here since you know
your picks are so let's move on to round
3 this is from Twitter user at our by
toe our Vito I don't know why does
everyone have such our Twitter name this
question which Pixar character should be
the next to get their own spin-off film
we were just talking about finding dory
of course - Dory zone spin-off movie and
any number of characters that could get
their own movie but which character do
you think is worthy of their own
spin-off and John we're going to start
with okay I so I wrote out like a whole
pitch for the spin-off movie I don't
want to do a super long thing here so
I'm gonna try to rein it in but just
give me that look um fair enough I mean
I understood the question as like which
Pixar character should get a spin-off
film right and to me I believe that
brave needs to be redeems that's a movie
that through circumstances outside of
Brenda Chapman's control fell short and
I think that there is so many there are
so many things that they had right in
beginning of that movie that if they had
another chance
if they focus on a different character
and sort of had a fresh take we can
finally get that fantasy Pixar movie
I've always wanted we've always wanted
yes so that's why I believe that
character should be the witch from brave
some of you know like the witch from
grave is one of my favorite Pixar
characters and I think this is a
character who deserves to be explored
and prequel territory I looked at really
good prequels like Rise of the Planet of
the Apes to take these characters that
weren't like a sidekick they weren't you
know the main character they were a
character that you know shows up and is
very compelling and sort of has a
suggestion we would explore a prequel
the younger version of the Wistrom brave
a long time before she would ever meet
more do and change his fate and stop the
kingdom from being taken over
we could have a young version of this
which at that point she would be an
apprentice wood carver when
one day you know she likes to carve
dragons not bears and one day a
sorceress shows up finds that she has
all this inclination to use magic so she
takes her on as her apprentice which she
starts to explore magic she learns how
to when she snaps inanimate objects come
to life amazing but her problem is that
she feels like she deserves you know to
have raw power she wants to accomplish
what her goals and what she wants with
brute force and brute strength
so she sneaks into the room she can get
to that Black Cauldron that we see in
grave she wants to craft a spell that
will change her fate but when the
sorceress tries to stop her she gets
that spell instead and turns into none
other than a Scottish dragon finally
know you have this dragon who's been
turned is nothing but pure aggression
and pure will rampaging the countryside
the young witch goes on an adventure to
go stop that dragon she has to deal with
the son of the king this prince who
tries to stop the dragon with brute
force she runs into these rebel thieves
who have a talking crow and she
impresses them with her magic and you
have this misfits adventure where the
young you understand a lot of things
like why does she love bears and wanted
to deal with the will of the whispers in
their connection with the head it all
has to do though with that central
narrative of the lesson that she learns
about both peace and strength all right
I call it the wood carver the wood
carver so figure your spin-off movie is
called a wood carver all right Edie
you're up next
okay okay I don't I don't know if my
pitch will be that long because I feel
like I'm going to save some of my points
for the rebuttal round fair enough okay
but here's the thing my character was a
Czech Jack from The Incredibles who is
just a great character period and
everybody knows that he's a great
character and I would love to explore
his tween or teen years interpreting it
that's what i'ma keep it vague maybe
this is what you know when you're really
clear that some producers let the
producers I have some little input so
they can feel like they did something so
this is it this is a John's is a prequel
and yours is a would be yeah mine is a
sequel and it takes place I would think
you know like I said in between to the
teens whichever whatever you try to
market to that day sure who everyone
pitching it to tweens or teens and
basically what's happened is there's
been a new super
here already Renaissance since the
events of the Incredibles now not only
is that the Incredibles who are back but
some of the other tertiary you know
superheroes are back and having a big
superhero party and doing some euro
stuff again and it's a grand new age of
superheroes but a dark threat
maybe somebody are related to syndrome
or maybe syndrome knocked up some
cocktail waitress and the Bahamas or
something and she's got some biracial
monster kid down somewhere haired with
dreads and he's mad about his dad being
dead and he captures all the superheroes
much like Syndrome trying to doom and
limiting all the superheroes he captures
all the superheroes including of course
Jack Jack's family now Jack Jack is not
some super duper superhero it's shown in
the earlier parts that part of how much
he uses his powers he doesn't really
know how to use his powers it's just
concerned of emotional and as you grow
up and you get told well you can do this
but you can't do that all those mental
blocks much like Franklin Richards they
block him from true access to all his
power so he's just sort of a disaffected
emo kid you know who's just like man my
parents are super his but screw that
that's lame you know he doesn't have
ready access to his power so he disdains
it and anyway yadda yadda yadda me and
Jack Jack Unleashed yeah he ends up he
ends up unleashing his full potential
because he has to it has to rescue his
family and he has to get together a
young bratty team of almost ready
superheroes including Frozone superhot
daughter who is a flame person obviously
she's she's a flame chick and to throw
out at the end of the movie she'll be
the only person able to assume a final
form that would be able to kiss her and
hold her and caress her through all
their romantic stuff that they've built
up over the movies so now that's my
perfect ending the flame girl and Jack
Jack and bracing is super flame powers
after they saved the day baby well there
you go that's the Jack Jack sequel Jack
Jack the teen years between there Jack
wick of check wait there you go
Perry alright who did you choose those
were long stories I'm going to do an
elevator pitch for the tank gang from
finding nemo and finding dory because
one in Finding Nemo they really held up
the second half of that movie quite a
bit I feel like when you deviate from
the main character and you go to that
second storyline there's a very good
chance that it could fall apart then I
mean we're
brought it up with some other movies
where it falls apart at the end part of
the reason why Finding Nemo is such a
strong movie throughout is because this
tank gang is so lovable and how they
take care of Nemo is just so delightful
you want to spend more time with them
you want to know what their early days
were like but I'm not going there I am
going this forward as a movie that takes
place after finding Dory because if you
sat through the credits of finding Dory
you know that the tank gang pop up out
of the ocean still in their little bags
right outside the Institute and they're
plucked up by volunteers and they're
obviously being brought in there so you
have a whole batch of lovable characters
that we still should know more about you
get to know them a little bit in Finding
Nemo now it's their time to shine with
Gale at the forefront and one thing that
Finding Nemo and finding Dory do that
I'd like to see them try a little
differently in a tank gang movie would
be to approach humans differently and I
think they do it really well in
ratatouille and it's very few other
movies where clearly linguini and Remi
have a special relationship I would like
to see a fish like Gill who is so tough
and hardened in that movie and clearly
has a big problem with darling the
dentist what would happen if he went in
there and see is that a human being is
actually trying to take care of him make
him better rehabilitate him and send it
back into the ocean so I'm going with a
tank gang movie okay gang sequel in the
aquarium we have the brave prequel about
the witch the wood carver and we have
Jack Jack between years guys what do you
think well the problem with brave is
well first off I'll be honest and I
appreciate how well thought-out both
pitches were but if I'm honest my eyes
glazed over a little bit partially with
braids because and I'm not hard on brave
I think braid deserves a little more
credit than it got exactly but we are
talking about what character should get
a spinoff and that's not just about
story potential it's also about what the
audience wants and it's also about what
is good for business for Pixar that
would probably be one of the worst
decisions and then with the Incredibles
the problem is that we're getting the
Incredibles 2 in 2018 so it's really
impossible to vouch for a Jack Jack
movie until we know what's going to
happen she feels bad in a way because
you're kind of pitching it as how i
would imagine like violet being with a
goth bratty person I would
it's weird too because the jack-jack
character taking him out of that
ensemble but we already got Jack Jack
attacked the short film and that's great
on its own
well many appalling but if we're being
rude you pitched a worse version of
Maleficent which didn't do that great
with the most beautiful woman in the
world better to stand in it that's not
what you look mister worst version and
oh and it's also somehow managed to be a
worse version of How to Train Your
Dragon I'm just like wow your is nothing
I've gotta change animal cheering
kangaroo horrible fantasy genres
together using there were sparks
together your genius at that also this
right here I'm really sorry
this I don't understand that I could
pitch better versions of each of your
movies that's what managing his powers
not having a baby coming out exactly we
have no assurance that they're going to
go tween or anything but by the way your
life come especially you have with
Randall no assurance they're going to do
that he might just be a dumb baby again
who has certain little little cutesy
things that he does but also in your
port your point about violet should be
the email one dude she's already had she
will have grown out of that by now
acting she send again wherever but him
him trotting some other territory makes
sense because I have the kids or
athletes not because they're going to be
different I like her for second huh yeah
I think tank gang thing I just don't
understand what the actual arc for Gil
is I do get that Gil's a great character
I understand and I understand you
focusing on him is smart I give you
points on that however what are they
doing I mean I I would taste like them
as a true Ocean's eleven stealing some
stuff they've showed they don't on their
back you know my party when Pixar tries
to put other genres action movies and
that's when we get things like cars to
which was a spy movie 12 it is that that
would be a rotten XO if there was a
movie that we've already gotten like
you're pitching a movie about their
characters in a location you've already
been to very similar to a story that
we've already gotten with characters by
all accounts and purposes their story is
over there's nothing left to say about
the same case not worried alright like
you said is there's another chance
that's why it should be done again so
they can actually get it done
okay so if they do that then no one will
see it but the tanking story is not is
not around whatsoever because they were
such a smug they were a small and
important part in finding Nemo and
clearly they had all been they touch on
it a little bit all been through stuff
that landed them in that dentist tank
then they've been through a lot that
land them in the Institute in the
Institute is such a rich place that even
though I think they use it very well in
finding dory there are so many exhibits
we don't know I don't want to drive I
would argue that both of your characters
got as much screen time as anyone could
stand
whereas Jack Jackie had his own spin-off
already as you said thank you for giving
me that point cuz I love that laugh but
it's just imagine how that would be if
he was actually cognizant and cogent was
a real human with real goals and so know
that I'm not on the jack how much better
that would be so guys let's bottom-line
it here I am the head of Pixar I wish I
would be going on to a very large house
yeah but I'm the head of Pixar you three
are we're doing a shark tank type thing
I'm going to green like one of your
movies you've got about 30 seconds you
have to sell me a lime green lighting
your movie over these other two Perry I
start with you all right so your green
lighting my movie one because the story
potential is there as I said we did not
get much of the tank gang in Finding
Nemo they are introduced at the end of
finding dory so your company's re paving
the way for a tank gang movie and
there's so much more to explore that is
Gil would be the forefront but there's
so much more that you can explore with
all of those characters that are very
rich and colorful characters and on top
of that you're running a company you're
going to want to greenlight this movie
because Finding Nemo and finding Dory
are proven successes people want more of
them you definitely didn't put that
little post credit thing in there for no
reason at all you did it because you
know that they have potential all right
John why am i green lighting as a wood
carver Pixar's track record has shown us
that when they try to do other movies in
worlds we've already been to with
different characters it almost never
works and it's never better than the
movie we already got which is why it's
so unique that we have this brave movie
that has a premise has a location that
we all want to see we all were excited
about brave leading up to that movie the
problem is they made it like Brother
Bear they have production problems but
here you have brenda chapman directing
this time she has full creative control
Megillah fog lighting
you of course wrote inside out you have
these two people who are going to come
they're going to a fresh start
they're going to take an inkling of a
character flesh it out and finally
commit to a medieval fantasy movie
that's about something new and original
it's going to be fully embracing the
Scottish folklore it's going to be
having the night it's going to be having
the castle of dunbroch
before things get more dark and drabby
in the more current version of brave and
the best part is it's going to redeem
great that's why it should get a spinoff
it's not for cash not because you know
who the characters are because you're
going to see that trailer you're going
to forget about the witch and you're
gonna be like I want to see the
woodcarver because that actually looks
like I'm good all right head sell me on
Jack Jack why is it going to green light
over these two okay look at his camera
okay look man I read the Redbird script
for Toy Story 2 and I know that it ends
with Jack Jack as a tween or something
so the bottom line is I feel as though
you could this could be a capable
spin-off of The Incredibles it's not
Incredibles to because it's more of a
graduation of the concept much like the
previous movie was like 50s through 80s
superheroes this will be 90s through now
superheroes with all their edginess all
their other social malaise all of their
apathy it's more like a version of like
if you like somebody like lead like
Legion or the new ways we've conceived
as superheroes we will show the movie
will show superheroes through a lens a
modern lens through a new generation of
superheroes and it's the only movie
where you actually have our child
be the hero rather than somebody
tertiary to parents this is your movie
to connect with all the kids
these guys will want to be Jack Jack
alright who has a big decision to make
Ilan anything to help not much to clean
up a lot of people really celebrating
this it's getting intense it's getting a
little brutal it'll come as can I pack
her for a second question and a lot of
arguments as well that a lot of people
saying brave they want to see a sequel
before they get a spinoff they want they
want to see more of that main story get
a chance to explore more of Marita
there's nobody here nobody in terms of
other characters Frozone and Edna mode
again coming
a ton I love those characters I also got
Jerry from Jerry's game the old man
playing checks he came up a few times
people want to see what he's been up to
very interesting then Richard I'm
curious just the permit from the couch
perspective you listen to these pitches
which one of these three would you go
see well I'd probably go see all of them
I think that John gave the best main
pitch but I think the parry had the
strongest closing yeah so now you're
that I don't know I think well if we're
going to see a witch spin-off I actually
kind of would want to see like the thing
that you pitched and like the Pixar
theory or whatever with like boo using
the time-travel door I want to know I
want to see like the connection of the
Pixar theory and have them prove it or
whatever I don't know how much I care
about like the dragons and stuff yeah
or whatever it is but uh yeah I don't
know yeah one well ed I'm Richard of
counter with you which is that and I I'm
sort of between Perry and John here I
think they hit you pretty hard on
Incredibles 2 on the fact that they kind
of hit those beats and previous movies
and again they were just both very
passionate about their choices so it
came down to me between Perry and John
and like any Hollywood studio executive
I have to choose between money and art
which is really going to do
conversations that we're having here
Perry you make a very compelling point
that finding Dory has the proven
potential of we've just seen these two
movies be massively successful and this
is probably a sure bet but John you know
your passion about the the woodcarver is
offset by the fact that the width of
that brain is not a very popular Pixar
movie I have to choose between those two
and I think what's putting me over the
edge is the idea of the argument that we
kind of already got the tank gang movie
and finding dory as far as characters in
an aquarium and that this would be a
different movie so I'm going to go John
and the woodcarver on this one but it's
very close
so Johnny's not going there I was
offering I know I love it I was very
close one what's what's I'm sure there's
a one who yelling at me right now this
is your second straight round really
bucking the trend 50% wanted Jack Jack
the movie 35% we're all about the tank
gang 15% went with the witch from brain
well I don't well if those 85 percent
we're sitting in this room listening to
these pitches I guess I doubt I know
what I'm pitching in the room you know
all right I'm going to hear about that
one that's a lot of judging is good fun
jump on the hashtag among people
watching there was a lot of enthusiasm
for the woodcarver I want to go see the
wood carver was tweeted more right
probably have to change the title title
TBD
let's go to Round four this is the one
that I've been looking forward forward
to just because you know we did an
honest trailer for a cars and cars to
here a couple weeks ago and we went into
a bit of a wormhole about the cars
universe because Spencer and Joe and I
and Andy we just don't get it we differ
so many questions that we don't
understand about the cars universe and
this doesn't have to be an incredibly
long round but we thought this would be
just a fun creative exercise so question
for Round four explain to me the
existence of the world of cars and
whomever I believe what most
satisfactorily answers my question
because I'm very disturbed and confused
by this world and so I would like to
hear you explain it and then I may have
follow-up questions I may not depends on
your explanations but the winner will be
who gives you the most satisfying
explanation of the world of cars how
they came to be why they are the way
they are and all of those wonderful
existential question the car is poses
and Edie I'm going to start with you
okay personally I feel as though you
have to think so far out of the box to
make cars make any kind of sense so with
that in mind this is my pitch alright
and and also this is this this is
universal and Pixar joining up for a
movie so they can both co-financed and
make it big in China because people in
America will not see this movie I'm
going to make
right now okay what I think happens is I
think transformers or gobots
whichever one you hate more were roaming
the earth and they were having a big war
with humans and we got down real like
terminator like terminator for level of
just like oh man we're barely making it
small group of rebel survivors are
holding on and their last hope is that
engage in EMP that will kill these
marauding robots that have been
murdering them for roughly a century and
one Kyle Reese type guy gets to the EMP
and he hits it and shifts out all the
machines but they reboot and they don't
remember that they're evil robots who
are bent on killing people they think
I'm a car I guess I'm a car and
they just drive around as cars with
their dumb eyes and you see how they
they use those those latent vestigial
transformative abilities to like move
their tires to grab stuff and that
that's the reason why they had that sort
of mobility so and I think what happened
to the human being
well the humans are all dead that last
Calvary's guy was probably the last
person and he died and basically also
they rebuilt society how their memories
that were implanted in them and just
like transformers come to earth and they
use radio signals to form their
personalities they had already done that
so that's what we get mater somebody
those are too many cable guy records
that's where mater comes from so the
last humans they're dying act of
humanity was to disable all technology
they rebooted as sentient cars and
that's our universe okay interesting all
right Perry please explain cars to me
all right
so you know how cars are getting smarter
and smarter we have cars that drive
themselves
so eventually cars become self-aware and
they start to realize that we've got
we're carrying these people around why
do we need them they're slowing us down
so they get rid of all the people and
the cars take over and they assume the
personality of the last person who drove
them and if that sounds familiar it's
because they're doing a lot of press for
cars three right now and that's the
explanation that the cars creative
director Jay Ward gave so it I find it
pretty satisfying I think it's probably
the most satisfying type of answer you
can get from a narrative perspective but
also you know I'm logical and I don't
like going crazy with rumors and all
that stuff so when I hear that the guy
who is responsible he's apparently
responsible for like the big manual on
cars that exists at Pixar when I hear an
answer like that from a guy like him now
I got the one-two punch and I really I'm
digging this answer
okay so again the same follow-up
question and maybe this was in between
the lines and you just wanted for the
sake of my weak stomach what happened to
the human beings cars got rid of them
cars so self-driving cars that as you
please and got rid of the human beings
okay I'm going to have the same
follow-up question to all of you after
your pitch and then I may just make my
decision just be aware John yeah what is
with cars explain it to me well you know
for me trying to understand cars with
any external information or trying to
like bring something really like out of
nowhere into it just makes me more
confused and it usually raises more
questions so my explanation ties into
something I literally wrote a book on
which I literally wrote an entire
chapter about what the cars actually are
and why I actually did because Jay bored
mentioned that the cars take on the
personalities of the humans that owned
them well part of that though is that
it's not an apocalypse where people died
or the cars got rid of them the first
cars came out self-driving cars weren't
really a thing yet and sorry I should
argue my own thing here yeah the cars
come to life the same way that the toys
come to life from Toy Story when humans
aren't around so somebody who's asking
these questions about cars movies
they've probably seen plenty of Pixar
movies I'm sure that they've seen Toy
Story so they can buy into that same
conceptual thing where machines that are
loved by humans they actually can be
autonomous and do things on their own so
what happened to the humans another
Pixar movie explains that the humans
were evacuated because they polluted the
earth and the cars decided you know what
the humans can't handle Earth we're
going to stay here and they decide to
act like humans and create their own
human society it's the only explanation
for a lot of plot
that happen in this universes yeah it's
a shared delusion where they have these
false memories where they think that
they were the humans after a while
because they have all these flashbacks
to Radiator Springs that boggles the
mind
how is Radiator Springs in 19 I was
there in 1954 in this universe like
there those are cars it's because those
are actually humans going through human
things but it's filtered through the
perspective of sentient cars that exist
because human emotion is what brings
them to life ok so and again and have my
follow-up question for all you after
this but just to summarize and you're
telling me that cars were transformers
Gobots
there's an EMP humans went extinct and
they are now the only surviving species
on earth Perry you're telling me that
these are sentient cars who basically
staged a coup exterminated the human
beings and now rule the earth job you're
telling me that cars come to life like
the toys and toys to wear when they
aren't around and they are remnants of
the human civilization that's left into
the wall-e spaceships I have one
follow-up question for all of you and
this is very important why do they have
tongues and I'm going to start with you
oh well in the horrible Michael Bay
films about transformers they've shown
an ability to transform it to actual
people so it's a remnant of that program
ok humans transformation all right Thank
You Perry white of course at tongues
those cars are super smart and they
needed tongues so that they could speak
to each other and say terrible lines
like every single thing that comes out
of toolmakers mouth it is materialized
over time because they needed it ok and
John why did the car set down same
reason they have teeth and eyes it's
because they want to be expressive
they love humans with humans left behind
so by filtering all of this and
pretending that everything around them
looks a little bit more human
so they rationalize things all right
guess the short round guys this is a
very simple concept and I think all of
you really really brought some great
theories lon I got please does anything
to clean up their factual oh so maybe
back
a lot of interesting theories remote
viewers a common one was Andy from the
Toy Story movies now is playing with
cars and I'm seeing what's in is that
Skynet came up a few times bath salts a
la sausage party the cars is not set on
earth that was a theory that came up a
few times just say a group like planet
where their cars and then perhaps my
favorite at Kim Hanley
it's a goddamn kids movie let it go
people said well Kim obviously doesn't
know what we do here what's that I have
to tell you I I was I was between
everyone everyone's theories appealed to
me a little bit I have to say that it
came down but largely to the last
question
Perry you almost won me over with the
fact that cars evolved tongues in order
to communicate with each other that is a
very good answer but John's idea of cars
developing eyes you need to just explain
tongues to me you explain eyes and teeth
you explain much more to me than I asked
for and it actually kind of made sense
so surprisingly I'm going to have to
give you the point on that one
thank you for kind of explaining car
sentences every wassup to John with
three any other point Perry you're not
out of it if you win this round then you
and N will have a tiebreaker to go to
the speed round so everybody's got to
got something to play for here around
five and of course we it's not an easy
question here in round five caleb
boatman at bc us underscore i'm batman
if you are Batman that's very very not a
very good way to hide your identity
asked who is the best Pixar villain mmm
this is Allah knows maybe not as many
big choices to choose from we'll see
Perry since your your back is against
the wall here I'll start with you okay
who did you pick as the best Pixar
villain I'm going with the og Pixar
villain and that would be Sid from Toy
Story now I was reading Toy Story the
other day in preparation for this and it
really made me appreciate the simplicity
of a villain who is just evil he is
rotten to his core
weird
inundated at this point with things like
superhero movies and really any kind of
genre of movie where they are constantly
explaining away a villains background
and CID just beautifully shows just how
vicious he can be and the fact that he
doesn't get some whole sob story we're
just watching a kid who is super
sadistic and he likes to torture toys
and kill them make them explode and
because it's not really explained away
he tends to be scarier he is scary while
you're watching him in the movie and
he's scarier when you leave the theater
you remember his face you remember those
braces that shirt it's the thing that's
just ingrained in your head and it is
absolutely mortifying behavior and it's
also kind of mortifying because you sit
there and you wonder where his parents
and not and not in the kind of situation
because I'm someone who likes to pick
you know rules apart not because oh it's
a kid in this parent should be on top of
him but like oh my god he is awful he's
going to grow out of doing terrible
things to toys and this world is just
going to like go to someone needs
to keep this kid in check I'm going with
it alright John who did you pick
you know I it was probably the easiest
question that we had uh that we were
discussing here because to me there's
one Pixar villain who stands out above
all of them and that is Syndrome from
The Incredibles syndrome from The
Incredibles is okay my favorite thing
about Syndrome just to get off on the
outset is that he is a guy who for
superheroes actually is self-aware of
the fact that he's in a superhero movie
and none of the other characters are
that line where he's like you got me
monologuing Jason Lee bring that to the
character and that whole thing where he
gets so wrapped up just for a second and
the fact that he's in front of his idol
there that is just an example of all of
the ridiculous nuance of in that
character it works so well he was named
buddy pine but he has hero syndrome
hence the clever name and what I love
about that is that his motivations his
reason for becoming a super villain are
so grounded in something that's like he
just wanted to be respected he wanted to
be accepted he didn't get that for me
I totally understand what it's like to
have like a fanboy sort of
get really frustrated with you and I'm
like you could be syndrome one day but
no wonder the view is that of actually
making him a threat I see himself points
out there's so many little touches
beautiful touch as they do with this
character the fact that he saves his
inventions for himself the fact that his
master plan isn't really what she would
expect this whole deal that he wants to
give weapons to everybody in the world
he is such a true villain because that's
not he doesn't just want to crush the
Incredibles he wants to make it so that
nobody could be Anna mr. incredible ever
again and he does that by making
everybody super and like that's the core
philosophy of the movie and it's
controversial the idea that like letting
the exceptional people be exceptional is
not something like I think I could have
like hour-long to base about which
people then the fact that you have a
villain in you're brave enough you're
Brad Burton you're directing and writing
your grave enough to introduce a villain
like that in the kids superhero movie
they nailed it there's no other Pixar
villain that says villainous and as
awesome I syndra at the same time all
right add who did you pick I picked a
lot so hug and bear from from Toy Story
3 and I'll be I'll be free from my
opening arguments the thing I find so
intriguing about Lotso is that his hate
does come from a place and I do
understand what Perry's talking about
about the over-analysis of villains you
know origins and whatnot but in his case
it's particularly affecting because he
made a choice to hate himself and hate
others like him because of how he was
treated now I don't want to get off on a
rant here but there's a bunch of groups
of people in this world who experienced
that because of how you're treated you
hate yourself and you hate other people
like you and you just nihilism and you
throw up you know you don't really care
so I think that that that is a thing
that would make a villain in real life
it makes many villains in real life and
I think that that's it's one of Pixar's
really most realistic for a
strawberry-scented bear a strawberry to
this bear is the most realistic
character that I've seen in a Pixar
movie so far and I just felt like I yeah
I'll leave with that alright three very
strong villain
left an impression pretty good things I
want to point out something about Sid
that when the creators of John Lasseter
and Pete docter and then when they were
coming up with the idea said they didn't
even want to create a villain they
didn't want to have a character in the
movie that was a real antagonist so like
that's why he comes off not only as evil
like you're saying but he really just
comes off as like a kid who started in
their way so to me I was like you can't
really say that that makes him the best
villain when you have syndrome who is aw
all the time he's after our main
characters and finding ways to make
their lives terrible in unique ways
syndromes elaborate plan is where his
weakness comes in I mean he essentially
is self sabotaging he loses in the end
because of flaws in his own design and
it's a great it is that it is that very
very lengthy backstory and his plan and
I think it starts to cross over a little
bit and really it's the same thing with
lot so to this that's probably one of my
least favorite scenes in Toy Story 3
even though I love the movie is right
when they're about to fall in the
dumpster and it's like in a split second
all someone had to do was say his
owner's name and that's it he just he
moved everything he just established and
the thing was sit I mean you brought up
realism before that is why I find said
to be the best the most memorable and
the most horrifying is because when I
look at Sid I definitely see a kid if
not an adult that can exist somewhere
nowadays because think about it and this
actually plays really well with who Andy
is and I think Andy is part of the
reason it's it is part of the reason
that Andy wines with becoming a strong
character in Toy Story because you're
looking at these two different kids and
how they play with their toys and it
winds up in one winds up enhancing the
other well I but I also think that in
that way what you just said Sid is also
a cipher he's meant to Jamie a mirror
character for Andy to trump up Andy
because we don't even realize because
because I mean I love that movie but we
don't he really get to meet Andy and
he's a set of feet in hands and he
doesn't you know to make a weird mirror
cipher for a character we don't alley
really get the characters into me where
there's multiple characters are meant to
enhance each other I was overhearing
he's too exaggerated for the role he's
supposed to have because they want to
make you hate him it doesn't feel like
he has a real justification and also
nothing he does is all that evil he just
sort of plays with his toys wrong it's
well I don't laughter
Leeroy story characters is a toys with
any sense of humanity at all which is
what we all do considering they're so
successful yeah I look at those toys
that he tortured and manipulated and
stitched together and made absolutely
miserable and terrified and I think oh
my god I understand why you're he is a
great effect on all of them well but
hasn't been established that he knows
for sure for sure that they're alive
like he can hear their screams and stuff
because I read I did some research and
it seemed like people were suggesting
that I'm just like I find it more
interesting that it was from his
perspective they're not real that's not
a lot of did or that was a lot so knows
that those dudes are real and if you let
them fall into a lava pit that they're
gonna die and also lots of you have to
retry to sink eat eat with like an extra
back story and where the movie falls
apart when I was watching 2033 I wasn't
there ready to get over with the lots of
stuff so that we could get to the really
good parts of choice or a 3d ending
something cuz his ending isn't even very
satisfying he's on the front of a truck
uh I'm going to do with him he has the
ultimate comeuppance for someone like
him because as stated in the movies he
feels as though all toys should be
destroyed all toys in and are too trashy
they got to go get destroyed they got to
be not anything anymore because of his
intense self-hatred so he gets his great
come up that's my being strapped to a
truck never dying
always inundated with flies forever and
ever and ever and so until that truck
becomes a damn car in the car universe
driving around another Friday so is that
like when you're watching that I mean
this isn't really anything we haven't
seen in a lot of other movies and TV the
original villain here is syndrome
because his master plan as said is I
never saw any other Asian oh you're a
dude jealous of superheroes that would
be one and pass them over I see
everything regretted every time Ricky
read is that Lex Luthor is almost that
that that sort of oh you're super I'm
jealous that would that was what's
interesting again it's a great superhero
allegory because they use a lot of
severe archetype machines but a lot so
I've never I've never seen someone whose
self-hatred
got in our favor gay then I'm there ah
okay
well appear so he's the best now cuz
it's because he's that way simple which
makes them the words giving it give me
quick fifty second closing on each of
yours eyes yours the best one better
over these two okay so it's not really
evil he's just a kid he doesn't do
anything very villainous when you
actually look at it and lots of hugging
very we've seen it so many other times
and honestly she's not a great character
to have around but syndrome enjoys every
scene that he's in when he's he still
seems the mr. incredible as I was
arguing earlier and his whole
comeuppance with the capes it has such a
great comedic beat and he's there to
underestimate Jack Jack and get to see
Jack Jack's power for the first time
he's in a better movie in these two
movies and it shows because he's a
better villain and he's a big reason why
the Incredibles is arguably one of the
best Pixar movies it has the best
exogenous alright and I would definitely
concede that that syndrome is a great
villain but we're talking about the best
of Pixar villains and their genre of
villain is normally pretty innocuous
pretty unthreatening who gets some sort
of mild come up into the end syndrome
dies which is bad seed becomes a garbage
man which is almost worse but um but my
but but lot so becomes a hood ornament
for eternity when all he wants to do is
die so he gets the biggest come up it's
because he represented the biggest
threat to the two of the Pixar
characters that we care about the most I
love The Incredibles but we don't care
about them the way we care about the Toy
Story characters he was menacing our
favorite Pixar characters and he got the
biggest comeuppance
and he had a lot of psychological
motivations he's the best and Perry said
all right so both good villains but I
think in our rebuttals we've kind of
enlighten lightened everybody on the
flaws and that's the problem with crazy
backstories as you wind up finding the
weaknesses in those characters and then
tripping over their own storyline
whereas with Sid I mean I use the word
pure before because that is something
that matters sometimes the simplicity of
someone's terrifying behavior is what
sticks with you and it's what radiates
out to all the other characters which is
the point of a movie with multiple
characters to enhance other characters
to make you fear for other characters
lives with those two they aren't as
scary
they don't stick with you quite like
SIDS creepy face and I'm a big fan of
horror movies and a big thing with
horror movies is that the second you
start explaining away of villains
motivation they become less scary it is
not only scary because of the situation
he's in and he's created but he's also
scared because he's haunting and he
sticks with you alright great arguments
on anything to clean up lots of people
arguing we should have allowed for
abstract concepts as villains or like
puberty / adulthood I'm going from Nemo
and Dory and death the concept of death
I would have entertained the concept
nobody go to them yeah also Kevin Spacey
has hopper came up a lot and uh Randall
from Monsters Inc whoever abandoned
Jesse the cowgirl mater mater was
mentioned and also a lot of debate on
the Twitter about whether we should
really consider CID a villain because
does he know that he's doing something
evil to these toys that was a frequently
debated topic still going on
yeah yeah part of your theory right is
that Andy's mom it was Jesse's owner is
that correct that's a different thing I
was a different man older difficulty a
whole other come on damn it I'm going to
get my picture period all mixed up and
it's a whole yet but it's a lot I have a
board in my office I'll show it to you
it's got mines of yarn and straight to
the whole thing oh man you guys really
did a great job selling me on all of
your villains and what it really came
down to is how you knocked each other
down and I felt like there were some
good knock downs for lot so with the
fact that he's kind of a retread of
stinky feet that we'd seen those
character beats before said aztlán said
the kind of knocking and Sid was is he
aware is he consciously evil or you know
is he just doing what a kid does and
then with syndrome you know the idea
that we've seen that kind of super
villain character before self-aware
jealous of the superheroes and in a
really close argument strangely I
actually think and it was really the
closing from Perry that won me over was
the idea
of the fact that he's effective that he
stays with you that he does create these
deformities now whether or not he's
aware of what he's doing is maybe a
different argument but as far as
effectiveness and sticking with you and
you guys didn't really hit her as much
on originality which I think you both
got hit on for your characters how
others had done it in a different way
and Perry's argument for originality
with Sid kind of got to me so I'd
actually aperi the point on that which
means and you and Harry are going to go
into a son's desk - please Clement man -
the speed round John John you're safe
you won't weigh in on this you're safe
you have a very point so n Perry you
were going to go one on one here and all
right here all right so this is a 50/50
question I will give you an option if
you both say the same answer whomever
says it first will get that answer the
other one will have to argue for the
other answer if you know twenty seconds
in the ten second rebuttal and this
point will not carry over but the winner
will advance to the speed rounds you can
only watch one of these movies which
would you choose cars to or the good
dinosaur I heard Perry oh the good
dinosaur first so and you get cards -
but Terry's going to go first you get a
little extra time to think your answer
out Perry cars - I'm sorry good dinosaur
why would you select that I selected the
good dinosaur because even though it's
not a picks our favorite it is still a
well done movie it is beautifully shot
and has a really moving story and Wow
even though the dinosaur is good cars -
is god-awful that is one of the dumbest
sequel ideas I've ever seen you have an
effective character Lightning McQueen
yet you decide to make your sequel with
home mater - a mater of all things
alright I personally think that they
were going for a sort of a weird True
Lies with cars type situation and as a
pitch I bet you that's what got it over
in the Pixar electrolyze well with the
cars so I think even as a pitch it works
better than
caveman jumps on the dinosaur and
meanders around for a while
caiman did not live with Dinosaurs this
is a basic fact parry ten seconds that's
why it's a really unique smoothing story
how they come together but I don't care
if that was the pitch that was sold it
is a poorly executed movie those two
genres should not have been mashed up at
all there is no fun in that
well the good dinosaur is bowel moving
because it's shitty I hate it it's it's
built on a big giant fallacy and at
least my movies took a daring swipe at
an incorporating genre all right one I'm
going to go to those arguments what did
you think uh you know I I actually think
cars 2 is not quite as bad as reputation
has it so I was I was all set to go with
it but I really don't feel like he kind
of gave me enough just from you know the
pitch would have been cool it's like
True Lies postcards like yeah but that
doesn't really say anything about the
movie so I gotta go to Barry Jon sorry
Richard what do you think yeah I think
that as argument sort of just evolved
it's bad I don't like it and I think MIT
have cards too so he pretty much lost
right out the game exactly I think that
I think end you got a little stuck in
the the premises and not so much
defending your choice so that was a
parry you get tough you don't get the
point but you will move on to the speed
round however John is still up 3 to 1 so
you have a little work to do if you want
to take the game Wow
and I'm going to come to you though I
want you to help me basically listen to
these arguments and help me make these
decisions on the speed round so I'm not
going to check out baby I'm here
neighbor rules you have 20 seconds to
answer ten second rebuttals and
specificity option or if you both choose
the selecting the same answer whichever
one of you says it first we'll get that
answer the second lap down a backup
answer are you guys ready
Thanks alright who's the better
supporting character and the mode from
The Incredibles or Doug from a mug oh
there you go everyone gets their first
choice Perry I heard you first would
Edna mode so you will go first 20
seconds whenever you begin Edna moons
the better character because everybody
still talks about is a perfect example
of a supporting character that
transcends the movie everybody loves her
and she is
so a very effective supporting character
because she drives the main characters
they wouldn't have deceived what they
did without her help both in designing
their suit and motivating them to be
better people and better superheroes and
better family together
she is definitely the better character a
really unique design all right and the
mode is a one joke character who's only
there at the layout exposition doug is
actually a character who brings change
into the movie with how the characters
feel and react the main plot swirl doug
is so much fun he's funny
he has heart he's in several scenes we
are like in saying that he's not a
memorable character people know what
that joke is right and they couldn't
even find a voice actress for MMO that
is a super cute character but he also
repeats the same thing over and over
where Edna has nuance
she is very into her fashion but she
also knows that she needs to serve these
heroes in a certain way so that they do
better by what their job is
without Edna we wouldn't have the
resurgence ten seconds here you go
make sure I have this yes don't think
this whenever you're ready with the
cultic oi John drove an uber with Edna
Edna mode she's only doing this on a
whim Doug actually goes through a
journey and has to defeat an Alfa he's
more of a character he actually has a
beginning middle and end and redemption
and a great ending where he gets to be
with Russells the rest of his life all
right
that is that was a hard-fought battle
Edie what do you think makes all those
arguments I mean the thing is I mean I
feel like parry was winning because she
was saying things like Edna mode drives
the plot and things of that nature but
then John came from the shoot tops with
a windmill dunk about how Doug not only
does he also help to drive the plot but
he also gets a satisfying like
resolution and he's part of what what
the resolution is whereas Edna mode does
start the New Age of superheroes but is
not integral to the end bigger siding
with John I have to side with John I got
it got me in the big one what are you
thinking yeah I agree that I was all set
to go then to mode and then John really
convinced me and
at last 10 seconds that like duck not
only is an integral character but super
fun the squirrel line is really
memorable so yeah I got to go John
Richard your thoughts I don't know
because I do think that Doug is the
better character but I think the
question was best supporting character
and Harry did a better job of explaining
why at the most supported the main
characters so that's where I'm stuck I
think the first round easily I'm with
you guys went to Perry I think she made
the blade out the best opening argument
and particularly why Edna mode supported
those characters her role in the overall
story John you did have a great closing
and I can see why these guys might be
swayed for it it's very close but I
think I am actually going to go with
Perry I think that you did lay out why
she was a better supporting character
and not just a memorable character so
Perry you get that first one you're
still behind three to two but you are
catching up alright question number two
what real-world toy should join the cast
of Toy Story Legos play-doh Legos and
play-doh all right John you say like
Isis perry you say play-doh
they rhyme I can't wait to hear these
John while I get a lot of the toys that
we've already gotten in these movies
have been kind of throwaway characters
and like look do you remember this right
with Legos you actually have an
opportunity to do something different
the toys room use haven't done before
where they can actually have Legos move
on their own and create entire cities
that the characters can go in so you
don't just have a new character you have
a new setting and you can actually have
like things happen and like they can be
a villain and they can like imagine the
toys having a fight Legos and big things
I'm going to go with a very similar
argument piggyback off of what he said
and say the same is true of play-doh
it's a toy that everybody knows it's a
toy that can be manipulated and turned
into new things where play-doh wins out
over Lego is that we already have the
lego movie there is no way Lego could
possibly be incorporated nor would they
want to do that when there's a popular
franchise that's already in existence
but play-doh
they can have at it because kids if you
Google Play Doh and Toy Story and all
that stuff they're building it John a
secular boat oh yeah if Toy Story could
have its he'll figure out Barbie they
can totally do it with Legos and they
can actually make jokes about the lego
movie and it can all be one big thing
whereas play-doh
it would be an animation nightmare be
everywhere and just one key is
interesting I actually look at it as an
animation challenge and who's better
accepting challenges like that
and Pixar and I'm pretty sure we live in
an industry where nobody know studio is
playing nice together there's no doubt
in my mind one of others would stop that
whoo
wow that was bet that okay that was back
at fourth like one money what do you
think Wow I mean interesting they
definitely both took it in a direction I
would not have expected I do think I
don't think John had a really good
answer for Perry though that there is
already a whole franchise about Legos
and animating with Legos and it does
feel like it kind of would be more like
merging these franchises than a Toy
Story
school so I think I'm going with Perry
okay Richard yeah I agree completely I
hope that the leg of everything would be
brought up and it was and I don't think
that John really rebutted it well enough
so gonna go with Perry all right and we
think I would also agree that the the
Lego thing has no rebuttal but my mind
is going wild with a t-1000 play-doh
dude rollin into it yeah that's sick you
know and I just feel like you know on
the basis of that it's sicker than Legos
without even a lego movie angle I was I
was EXO I was on the fence I was leaning
toward Perry but I think you guys
unanimously kind of that the whole thing
was I didn't get alive what what role
play-doh would play but I agree that the
whole lego movie saying very tough
I will go with you guys I will side that
was a close decision for me anyway and I
will side with Perry and Plato so that
actually ties us up three to three with
three questions left question number
three inevitably fidget spinners have
come up several times I'm sure Anna
managed to come up everywhere debited
Lee and they had just a week we got this
question and it was ticked off of the
original list my pick was going to be
Skeletor Kitson one dudes water around
looking for his enemy the whole time and
not being able to find it but trying to
find some new ways to be evil that's all
right good this is a fun question what
famous person's brain should be the
setting for inside out to Jimmy Neutron
ah famous person's brain famous person
famous character so if it has to be
Pixar appropriate it is the inside out
too so it will be a Pixar film I'm going
to say George Lucas alright in either
Jimmy for George Lucas's brain I love it
already
I like that John Jimmy Neutron tell me
about it what are you music things about
Jimmy Neutron is that his emotions guide
everything he does but he's also very
like logical so you can have this
conflict between the science and the
having to be a little bit you know like
callous but fighting with emotion and
empathy you can bring in new emotions
that they didn't have in the inside out
movie like loves because you already
have a great love interest and his best
friend is what's your name so I think
George Lucas's brain would be an
excellent setting for a full movie
because we'll look at the emotional
rollercoaster that guy's been on you
probably have emotions changing places
with that Control Board all the time and
could you imagine what his personality
Islands might look like I mean not even
just a Star Wars Island but all the
incredible movies that he's created
where it just it speaks to his
creativity and he has just delivered an
incredible body of work that would be in
there ten seconds George Lucas is like
too many archetypes though and it's too
much Star Wars it's too much Indiana
Jones and stuff that like there should
be a Pixar movie with like original
ideas and a real conflict at the center
of it it should be emotion versus logic
that's what would make it a good picks
up
yeah but mine would be a lot more fun to
watch than that because not only do you
have Star Wars in Indiana Jones you
things like American Graffiti he is a
human person and think about all the
creatures that would exist where
bing-bong lives how many creatures much
George Lucas come up with alright I'm
leaning one way Richard quickly quickly
which way would you go
yeah I mean George Lucas is the one that
I would see but we did establish that
this is going to be a real Pixar movie
and I think that sounded a really good
job of filling the emotional aspects of
it so I would go with Jimmy Neutron lon
uh yeah I mean I I do I have to concede
that I think Jimmy Neutron makes more
logical sense but I really want to see
this George Lucas a movie I got it
I feel like I feel like that's the one
that stands out to me is like I am
curious about what that movie would be
ed what do you think I mean if the
criteria is strictly what would be easy
to make a Pixar movie based on these
arguments but it based on these
arguments as George Lucas all the way
because either you guy you got me with
where we're big monolith or that that
stupid green version of Chewbacca is
showing out down there a blue Yoda who's
like a yodeler something is down there
lightsabers that f-15 you know that look
like Jack's oh there's so many things
down there so yeah I'm torn I kind of
disagree because I think that John kind
of sold me on what the movie itself
would be which would be logic versus
emotion that for me so many got a better
movie other than the y'all Perry I get
the Star Wars stuff and you know I kind
of know what would be in your movie but
I feel like John XR slowly a little bit
better than what the movie itself would
be so I think actually gonna side with
John on this one with Jimmy Neutron so
that leaves us down to John if you win
this you win the game Perry if you get
this point we will go to the final
question make it a good one what Pixar
movie when you want to live it
Incredibles Incredibles
[Laughter]
up Oh
all right Perry would like to live in
the incredibles John we want to live in
up Perry I heard you virtual person what
person has not dreamed of living in a
world where superheroes exist and it
doesn't have to be a situation where I
could be a superhero
I could either be a normal person being
inspired by superheroes in all their act
and not turn into a syndrome and there's
also people like Edna mode who can
create and find something that they love
to support them there's just so many
possibilities to do something really
special and important with your life all
right John up well first of all is
established an Incredibles aren't
superheroes aren't anymore just super
villains I don't like that kind of
environment too dangerous
so with up you get to have dogs that can
talk and also not only could I be able
to talk to my dog which would be way
more interesting than other people
getting superpowers I don't get to have
is that I get to live in this world full
of amazing shape language where people
are the shape of things that like
represent them rustling hey I would much
rather live on the edge in a dangerous
world than one that makes me sad all the
time and God forbid dogs Dougs collar
breaks who is there to fix it and then
you've just eliminated as a coolest part
of being in an up movie is a talking dog
the very fact that this technology
exists is great but in Incredibles you
have AI that can defeat any of the
supers I don't wanna live in a dangerous
world because I want to live and I want
to hang out with a dog I want to live in
a world where that technology exists and
I could actually use it
ooh Richard what do you think I don't
know I got to be honest I don't really
love either of those pigs pretty much it
I feel like outside of the adventures of
the movie those are basically both just
two birds right so I think that perry
sold me on like earth whoever I just
completely forgot I've had with RV but
whoever wasn't incredible I would side
with because I enjoyed
this is Josh yeah no I would I would go
against incredibles if only because you
know like you said it's too dangerous
yeah there and I feel like that's sort
of a negative and other than that
neither of them really had any negatives
or positives and when they say if I was
a superhero certainly the incredible is
number one but damn it
living in up I mean I pick up and when
I'm in one of the early rounds is you
know because I really like that movie so
the shape language thing is really cool
talking to Doug so super cool and just
imagine that the the the adjunct
technology that would come out of that I
have to agree I think that the idea of
being too dangerous and also the idea of
the talkative dogs and everything that
sounded like a bit of a cooler world to
me so I'm going to give John the point
which means John win Pixar's right
congratulations congratulations to
everyone in here they have one quite
such a great place you will feel for
this guy thank you so much for coming in
ad where can people find you ed career
well yeah ed Grier destroys on all
social media that's my handle so yeah
that deviantART I'm an artist as well as
the comics though yeah you can go check
out my art on there and I do a podcast
called nerd goat was just ranking that
greatest the characters are from fiction
of all time awesome check it out
podcasts are demand the Renaissance man
a man of many talents Perry where can
people find you i'm on twitter and
instagram @ PM er off and i'm all over
the collider videos youtube channel john
Negroni obviously looking out for Pixar
theory 2.0 but where can people find you
in the meantime if you're interested in
Pixar theory stuff it's all on John
agree calm or just find me on twitter
i'm only doing stuff at john Negroni
I also host a podcast called cinema hall
x4 we got this covered I think he our
dimension bit where we talked about
movies and sometimes I and like super
insufferable and yeah and then there's a
Pixar theory back and all that stuff you
can find in everywhere if there's
anything that the personalities here on
screen joke you can relate to it that
sometimes are all a little unseparable
professional i know that i get very
angry sometimes on the show lawn harris
on the couch richard higginbottom's
thank you for joining us on the i am
yeah thank you for having me people
where can people find you on twitter you
can find me across town at the wrong'd
applied building yes and also you can
also find me on youtube I did a I did a
fan-made honest trailer for movie fights
so yeah so you can find that andy
tweeted it so apparently it's good or
something so find that and then while
you're there stick around on my channel
and subscribe because i need more views
and stuff awesome thanks guys thank you
for joining us for pixar fight thank you
for watching at home if you're watching
a Tremec as plus we will be doing a
quick after the fight in just a few
minutes so stay tuned for that if you're
wondering about the belt match between
myself and Mike Carlson that will be
happening in early July we will be
announcing that date soon but don't
worry we didn't forget me versus Carlson
one-on-one until then you can find me on
twitter at merle dan thank you to our
panel thank you guys for watching we'll
see you next week